thank you Father
for what you bring us
our Father in Heaven feeds the birds at
the air how much more will he give to
you watch my friends over to watch TV
not unlike this TV that just showed up
magically and not everybody can fit on
my one couch and I thought to myself
well if there was such a thing as a bunk
bed but as a couch introducing the
double-decker couch so everyone could
watch TV together and be buddies that
was literally the dumbest thing I've
ever heard
please file style let me handle this
that idea is just the worst never seen
one before
no the toilets were like 10 minutes
before the captain died five minutes
before that I saw a woman in her she's
70 years old she said you went in after
her and she doesn't have Alzheimer's
if you're wondering are you asking me if
I saw someone else go in or if I killed
the captain not really cutting down the
cherry tree
oh well crap what it's true how do you
know I just know did you read it in the
book
no so how do you know Sherman how do you
know you told me who told you tours
Washington
George Washington yeah
liar my odds are still no